twins i dressed up as jenna today
jojo siwa goes brunette and totally
twins with her dancing with the stars
partner jenna johnson it's just awesome
the 18 year old dance moms alum debuted
her new do on instagram over the weekend
posting these snaps with the dancing pro
alongside the caption quote it's almost
halloween so today i decided to dress up
as jenna johnson yeah not only are they
rocking identical red rehearsal outfits
with denim jackets jojo added that she
made sure to hit every detail from head
to toe no like literally she dyed her
hair brown and painted her toes to match
i love that that's my favorite thing
ever the triple threat also shared this
clip to tick tock saying she quote
really went full out brown hair and all
so what does jenna think of jojo going
full out jenna for halloween
the 27 year old shared this tick tock
writing in part quote it's the details
for me hello we're twins we're twins yes
sir
i am me she is she except when i pretend
i'm hurt the two seem to be having a
blast together on the hit dancing
competition it's been fun it's been a
lot of fun jojo posted this clip to tic
toc testing jenna's tic-tac knowledge
what does it mean if it's a bones day or
a no bones day
does this have to do with halloween no
i have no idea cool what's the sound
associated with this oh i hate this one
skirt
is it skirt ice
oh what is this from
yeah
[Music]
sure last but not least what is this
thing
yeah
i knew that because i found video of
youtube
you got one out of four
yeah so jenna didn't exactly crush it
but jenna did make jojo try kombucha for
the first time and she didn't exactly
crush that either cheers
do you love it no yes you do you're me
cheers
i'm trying to burp like you have to get
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
don't disrespect kombucha like that last
week jojo opened up to et about a
personal breakthrough she had thanks to
jenna who asked her to take off a baggy
shirt she was wearing during rehearsals
and i was like i can't and she was like
why and i was like because i don't like
the way that i look under it
and she was
like no and she was like you said to me
you said i'm your partner
you have to trust me
take it off like you're wearing
something under it literally take it off
and then i started crying and i took it
off and i went up to the mirror and she
made me say a lot of things to myself
that i never said before never thought
and now slowly but surely i'm finding
myself i'm finding how i feel about
myself
[Music]
you